I try to make it seem like I'm just
getting this out,
but I know all the moves.
I know every little piece of it
just here,
just go here.
This is what a Louis Ck joke looks like.
It's a short one,
only 207 words,
but there are 207 words that are chosen,
very purposefully practiced until every
one counts for something.
Today,
I want to go through this joke beat by
beat and explore how Louis C K
Constructs and performs his comedy.
My girls are six and nine now.
They're actually a really exciting age
because they're learning to do some cool
stuff.
I played monopoly with my kids.
That's really fun.
Every joke has to have a premise,
an idea that the inevitable punchline
will snap comedically into place.
The premise should be really clear
whether it's implied as in some one
liners or stated outright.
As Chris rock once said,
a lot of comedians have great jokes and
they don't like,
why isn't this working?
It's not working because the audience
does not understand the premise.
In this case,
the premise has two parts accomplished
in two senses.
First Louis is playing monopoly with his
daughters and second,
my nine year old.
She can totally do monopoly.
This world actually totally gets how the
game works,
but she's not as emotionally developed
enough
to handle her inevitable loss in every
game of monopoly.
The second part of this premise is
beautifully structured because besides
very lucidly delivering the premise that
this joke is going to be our six year
old girl learns what it means to lose in
monopoly.
Louis,
we actually get some laughs out of the
sentence by the addition of a couple of
words and a strategic rhythm.
I mean the simplest way to end this
sentence is to say that she's not
emotionally developed enough to handle
losing it monopoly,
but instead he said
to handle her inevitable loss in every
game with monopoly.
In this way,
Louis adds to little comedic surprises
in the premise and make sure to include
a pause so that each can be appreciated
in their own.
How to handle her inevitable loss in
every game with monopoly,
because the monopoly last is dark.
It's heavy
mediums like Louis CK,
are experienced enough to master not
only their own delivery,
but where the laughs will occur in their
jokes and how to deal with them.
Telling a joke is like riding a wave of
feeling and if you watch Louis Ck is
comedy,
you'll see that during laughs.
What he does is emphasize his last line.
It doesn't give the audience new
information.
He augments the information just given
something that he actually learned how
to do brilliantly from Jerry Seinfeld.
I'm opening for Jerry in front of like
12,
$100 or $20,
2,500
people and people are applauding bits
and I had never encountered that and I
didn't know how to handle it.
I asked Jerry what to do and he said,
you stay in the bed,
you stay in the.
They're reacting to if you're angry and
that's why they're applauding.
You stay in that energy because a
monopoly laws is dark.
It's heavy
candy.
Maybe you didn't get to win.
The choice of candyland here though
Louis acts as if it was pulled out of
thin air is the perfect counterpoint to
monopoly.
It's visual,
the game pop straight into your mind is
an object of colorful innocence.
The drama and the funny voice is also
performed like it was spontaneously made
up,
but the words and the images he uses
like Fudgie thing and gummy twilio's are
carefully chosen to enhance that visual
sense.
Louis is never not in control and that's
important because since the premise has
been so strongly set up in the
counterpoint drawn out so vividly,
the laughs that Louis gets here or
actually lapsed in anticipation of a
punchline,
not yet said the audience is already
imagining how dark the monopoly last is
going to be.
Just watch how he gradually increases
these anticipatory laughs like the
audience is a fiddle to the final three
word punchline,
but when she loses it monopoly,
I got to look at her little face and I
go,
okay,
so here's what's going to happen
now.
Okay,
all your property,
everything you have,
the railroads,
your houses,
all your money,
that's mine.
Now gotta,
give it all to me.
Give it to me.
One thing Louis doesn't get recognized
for enough,
in my opinion,
is his ability to dramatize in his jokes
when he acts out this conversation with
his daughter.
The light touchy gifts,
especially with that hand movement right
on the punchline,
really locks the audience into the space
where he wants them to be.
The audience needs to see the situation
from a six year old perspective for it
to work.
Then if he succeeded,
the tags or the two additional
punchlines that follow will be that much
more devastating.
Hilarious and no,
no,
you can't play anymore a see because
even though you're giving me all of
that,
it didn't even touch how much you owe
me.
Doesn't even touch it.
Baby.
Going down to heart is really bad.
Putting the audience in the perspective
of a six year old is important for
another reason because I think on a
deeper level,
Louis is actually trying to make a
comment here on the actual ruthlessness
of the economy we live in where property
really is taken away from people
sometimes by monopolistic interests,
with debt to spare.
That's the thing.
His daughter is not emotionally
developed enough to comprehend and when
we see it through her eyes,
the reality seems even darker than it
usually does,
especially in the final tab.
All you been working for all,
hey,
I'm going to take it now and I'm going
use it to destroy
your sister.
Just mayhem on this board for her.
Now you know more than anything else,
I think I'm obsessed with articulation,
with the magic of putting things just
the right way.
There are 207 words in this joke and not
a single one is wasted.
They're used either in meaning or in
rhythm to contribute to the overall
effect and effect that lets us see the
world from a different angle and more
importantly makes us laugh like great
poetry,
great standup comedy is language
distilled to its most potent form and
these days few people distill it better
than Louis Ck.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and thank you to the
great courses plus for sponsoring this
episode.
If you love learning,
which I do,
obviously a great courses plus is a
subscription on demand video learning
service,
which essentially means that it's got
great college level lecture series
online about 7,000
subjects,
literature,
math,
science,
how to be a better photographer,
whatever from some Great Ivy League
university professors.
I'm learning something right now about
how great science fiction works because
if there's a course in science fiction,
I'm going directly for it.
Um,
if you go to the great courses
plus.com/nerd
writer,
it was a link in the description for
that and get a free month.
It's 1490 $9 per month after that.
It's just a great service.
If you want to sort of take some cool
lecture series.
Thank you so much for that.
Also,
nerd writer,
nerdwriter.
It's finally I figured these out.
I really wanted to get the right color
and the right fields so you would want
to actually wear them outside and inside
DFTA figured it out in the best way.
You can go there and buy one of these.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'll see all of you next Wednesday.
I did.